I know I'm not as smart as you know
maybe I can't analyze and theorize and
speculate on why we behave the way we do
you read all of those books not me but I
do know one thing I know how I feel I
know that I can stand here watching you
try to destroy everything I've ever
wanted in my life wanting to smash your
face in with my fists because you won't
make even the slightest effort to opt
for happiness and still know that I love
you that is always so clear to me it's
the one place I get all my strength from
you mean so much to me that I am willing
to stand here and take all of your abuse
and insults and insensitivity because
that's what you need to do to prove that
I'm not going to leave you I can't
promise I'm not going to die George
that's asking too much but if you want
to test me go ahead and test me if you
want to leave Leave but i am not the one
who's going to be walking away now I
don't know if I can take it for forever
but I can take it for tonight and I can
take it next week next month I may be a
little shaky but let me tell you one
thing George i feel so good about myself
better than I felt when I ran away from
Cleveland and was frightened to death of
New York better than I felt when I
thought there was no one in the world
out there for me and better than I felt
the night before we got married and I
thought that I wasn't good enough for
you I am I am wonderful I am nuts about
me and if you are stupid enough to throw
someone sensational like me away then
you don't deserve as good as you've got
I am sick and tired and running of
running away from places and people and
relationships you want me
then fight for me because I am fighting
like hell for you George